admitted liar Alec Murdoch spent another
six hours on the stand in his own double
murder trial today the disgrace former
lawyer and accused killer used that time
to test his own theory about what
happened to his wife Maggie and Son Paul
it relates back to a 2019 uh alleged
drive drunk driving boat accident it
crashed and killed a 19 year old on
board
I didn't believe that any of the
families the people that were involved
in the boat wreck had anything to do
with hurt and Maggie and Paul but I can
tell you that at that time and as I sit
here today that I believe that boat
wreck
is the reason why Papa and Maggie were
killed so we've got random Vigilantes
because of the boat rack now I don't
know that they're random Vigilantes what
you're telling this jury is that it's a
random vigilante that's your 12 year old
the 12 year old five two people
that just happen to know that Paul and
Maggie were both at Mozelle on June 7th
that knew that they would be at the
kennels alone on June the 7th and knew
that you would not be there but only
between the times of 8 49 and 902 that
they show up without a weapon assuming
that they're going to find weapons and
ammunition there that they commit this
crime during that short time window and
then they travel the same exact route
that you do around the same time to
Almeda
that's what you're trying to tell this
jury
you got a lot of factors in there Mr
Waters all of which I do not agree with
but some of which I do
joining me now our criminal defense
attorneys Brian Claypool and Phillip
Holloway and adjunct law professor at
Northwestern Andrew stoltzman gentlemen
thank you for joining me I want to get
your all of your reaction to this
question which is I'll start with you
first Brian what is the most damning
evidence that you've heard against
Murdoch in this trial
yeah I got three words for it Sean
consciousness of guilt I mean Murdoch
lied about the most material fact in the
case he told law enforcement in two
interviews I was at home on June 7th on
the evening of the MERS I dozed off fell
asleep and then through this videotape
this Snapchat video that that Paul took
he actually is at the kennel so he's
lied about that and then what he does is
he goes into court and then he talks
about all these other theories why is
that important because it is devoid of
human heart and human emotion I mean his
testimony Sean was coming from a lawyer
not a grieving father and a grieving
husband and I think that is just going
to be devastating for him and the
prosecutor Sean over 25 times I was
counting today he kept using the word
you lied this lie when did you determine
you were going to lie the jury hears
this ad nauseum it's close to closing
argument this time frame now you've only
got a few minutes for him to to leave
and for somebody to come and kill them I
mean it's devastating for his defense
Philip
well good evening Sean thanks for having
me look I think one of the best things
that the prosecutor brought out today
during cross-examination he got the
defendant to admit that there was nobody
else down there at that kennel in the
moments leading up to these murders
other than himself and the two victims
he got him to concede that point and if
that's the case if he didn't kill him
who did and I think that's probably one
of the strongest points that the
prosecutor made however the prosecutor I
think has overplayed some of their hand
because they have not been able to
establish motive despite all the
testimony about all these Financial
crimes and there's a lot of them to be
sure and despite the fact that he's lied
and he's admitted he's lied they have
not been able to tie any of this stuff
up to a motive a reason to kill this uh
this man's wife and his son and the jury
is listening for that and of course we
all know prosecutors don't have to prove
motive but when they do it needs to be
something that's credible because that
will take away from The credibility of
the rest of their presentation yeah
Andrew what do you think
yeah I think Alex Murdoch and his legal
team made a big big mistake by having
him testify it violates rule number one
a criminal defense law never let your
client testify because Alex Murdoch made
admissions with respect to you know
lying about The Alibi with respect to
stealing 3.5 million dollars from his
clients and having a major opiate
addiction it's a huge huge problem you
tie in The Alibi and the lying about it
these jurors are saying wait a minute if
I was in this position and my wife and
my son were killed what would I do what
I wouldn't do is lie about where I was
so I think he's going to be convicted
and I think he's going to be convicted
on his own words so is it possible I was
a D.A for 10 years spent a lot of time
in a courtroom and even when that last
time I was in was 12 13 years ago even
then they everyone watched FBI Crime
files and they want to see DNA evidence
and fingerprints they think you're going
to get in these cases what they see on
TV which we all know you don't but can
that come into play in this case or not
really Brian
yes Sean that's a great point and I
think that's why there is a potential
for a hung jury there's no way Murda is
ever going to be acquitted but you might
have one or two jurors on the stand that
are going to go back and deliberate and
say hey wait a minute we don't have the
weapons we have a very little gunshot
residue and an expert said that gunshot
residue could have come from a year ago
and there's very little blood on Murdoch
so you combine those three lack of
forensic tangible evidence and you could
potentially get one juror to hang this
case but look at the end of the day you
can prove a fact through inference you
can prove a fact through indirect
evidence so you know I think there's a
larger chance he gets convicted than a
hung jury yeah no doubt about that okay
Philip at the end at the very end of the
cross-examination today the prosecutor
asked this take a listen
when you testified on Direct yesterday
and you were asked about
leaving the kennels with your new story
your words were
I got out of there correct
I believe that's what I said yes sir
and you also said
during your testimony
on cross-examination
that you hurt the ones you loved the
most didn't you
I did say that Philip
yeah but see here's the thing he gave
him an opportunity to go and explain
that he did that all through
cross-examination and by the way I don't
think it was a mistake I think that the
defendant all things being equal has
testified very well the prosecutor has
not asked leading questions they've
asked open-ended questions they've asked
questions that they didn't know the
answer to and because they have done
those things that violates the basic
rules that we all have learned you know
in terms of trying cases and trial
advocacy and because they've done those
things they've given him the opportunity
to run away with the discussion in this
courtroom has he admitted he's a liar of
course he has and he's admitted that
he's a thief but he's been able to make
the case on cross-examination that he's
the liar and he's a thief but he would
never kill his wife and his son so I
think the prosecutor has probably not
had the Perry Mason experience that
they've been apparently trying to get
the defendant is I think dominating this
discussion in that courtroom Andrew
maybe that's my last question for you
because I I just started watching the
testimony yesterday and I got to tell
you what I thought Murdoch did a pretty
good job and he had a wide leeway to
tell his story to the jury and become
somewhat likable even though I know he's
a no liar what say you
yeah look he's a Charming guy he's an
attorney he was a prosecutor for a while
so he came off about as well as you can
come off but the problem is from the
drug addictions to stealing from your
clients to doing all these nefarious
horrific things there's a lot of people
who are sitting in prison right now
based exclusively off of circumstantial
evidence and I think Mr Murdoch is going
to be the next one all right gentlemen
we're going to see what happens thank
you for joining me and thanks for your
insights appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else